I would be terrified if I got onto a plane
and I saw a woman flying the plane.
If I see a black pilot,
I'm gonna be like, boy,
I hope he's qualified.
There hasn't been a fatal commercial flight disaster
United States since 2009.
And airline experts
lawed flight safety for being at its highest in 2023.
Because it's not about the safety,
it's about the diversity.
And while we're at it,
let me add. What diversity?
About 92% of pilots in flight engineers are white.
92% are men.
That's according to the Bureau of Labor Statistics.
Black pilots and flight engineers
grew from 2.7% in 2018 all the way to 3.6% in 2023.
That's right.
All this angst for 1%,
ain't no crashes to point to.
Y'all don't even have diversity to point to.
Now here's my favorite fact, though.
Cause you remember that bowling flight
where the door came off?
The pilot who landed that plane was a woman.